your mom is such an accomplished uh
woman she's uh
she's the doctor for the fire department
of new york right i mean she's
the chief chief medical officer for the
for the whole city for the whole fire
department
on 9 11 she was one of the first
responders she ran down there
she literally is on the scene and and
both buildings collapsed
while she was standing there uh she was
there to rescue firemen
who needed medical treatment i mean
she's a genuine hero
she's extremely you know extremely
modest
you would never she's she doesn't like
you know act
a heroic or a normal life and even more
than that day
she was such a long-term heroic to so
many families
in the fire department like that was her
full world and life
and the people she loved so much like
really really loves firefighters and is
always
would always be there for them and in
the same way she felt like they were
they were there for her
pete davidson grew up on staten island
like you
his father was a firefighter who died at
uh 9 11.
did your mother know pete davidson's dad
yeah she knew him um you know through
the department she
she deals with every she has to give
physicals to everyone she has to give
you know uh and
follow up with everyone clear everyone
for duty
you know if they want to join the
department if they want to
get back to if they're injured or
anything so she knew him and
part of her job is she she has to tell
the families of of uh of anyone who die
if someone dies in the line of duty she
has the she had to break the news to
uh the families of the firefighters and
because of that like certain people she
bonds with and she cares about pete
beyond his comedy career
and and pete's family um isn't it weird
that you and pete like ended up at
saturday night live i mean
what are the odds it's very strange i
mean the the fact that two people from
staten island
are on the show i bet when lorne when
lauren started in the 70s he could not
have wanted anyone from staten island
anywhere near
you don't think so there's no way but we
don't we don't really talk about it it's
just a strange
it's just like a strange thing